Hey hummingbirds!
You think you’re so perfect, fluttering
around, lookin’ all pretty?
Well we finally found a way to make you look
clumsy and dumb!
Just like us!
Hey bird lovers!
I’m Chastity, filling in for DNews.
Hummingbirds are incredible creatures, aren’t
they?
Just watching them in flight, darting from
flower to flower, is awe-inspiring.
To drink nectar from flowers, hummingbirds
rely on their ability to hover.
But how do they do it?
Engineers from Vanderbilt University teamed
up with a biologist from University of North
Carolina at Chapel Hill to create a detailed,
aerodynamic simulation of hummingbird flight.
The simulation demonstrates that the way a
hummingbird flies is much more closely related
to insects than it is to other birds.
Unlike other birds, Hummingbirds can generate
lift not just on the downstroke, but on the
upstroke as well.
This happens by inverting their wings.
Larger birds get practically all of their
lift on the downstroke.
Insects, however, can also hover, fly back
and forth, and side to side.
Their wing construction may be different,
but like the hummingbird, insects also produce
lift from both the upstroke and downstroke.
Hovering, in itself, is an amazing feat that
requires intense visual processing.
But two researchers from the University of
British Columbia claim to have found a glitch
in the hummingbird hover system.
The researchers found that altering a hummingbird’s
visual stimuli while it attempts to feed causes
the bird to falter in flight.
The hummingbirds were put into a laboratory
flight arena.
They hovered around a plastic feeder in front
of a surface that projected images.
When still images were projected, the birds
had no visible response.
Moving images, however, seemed to trip their
game up.
A rotating spiral, for example, caused the
hummingbirds to drift backward repeatedly
as they tried to make contact with the feeder.
Kind of like me trying jog and drink water
at the same time.
The poor hummingbirds still could not get
used to the moving images when the researchers
repeated the experiment.
When the bird’s beak broke contact with
the feeder, a re-boot was triggered - the
bird would come back to its original hover
position, only to get tripped up again by
the same images.
The researchers explain that this experiment
suggests quote - “the hummingbirds' visual
motion detection network can over-ride even
a critical behavior like feeding."
These findings could open a door to more research
on other interesting ways that flying birds
use visual information.
Tell us about your favorite bird in the comments
below, and check out more cool science videos
here.
*point below* And don’t forget to subscribe
for more DNews.
I’m Chastity and I’ll see you next time.